what did you get out of the the shooter
rounds and talking to the coaches as you
get ready for today Kirk you know
everybody that thinks of June 21st is
being the summer equinox or whatever
it's the longest day of the year has
never come to an NCAA tournament ten
hours watching practice and then done
four games the next day you know you get
little bits and pieces as like watching
Texas Tech's practice yesterday for
instance was amazing
Chris beard who's one of the finalists
for Coach of the Year and he's had a
fabulous season everything they do in
practice is so regimented and apparently
they do it all the time that way and
they had different music for different
spots on the floor they had a lot of fun
they walk arm-in-arm from one end of the
court to the other saying the word
together together together that's been
their theme so things like that you know
that you don't normally see when you go
to a practice when you do a
regular-season game I guess so there's a
little touch of that you get a chance to
to meet some of the kids that you
haven't seen play in northern Kentucky's
got the Player of the Year their
conference and Andrew McDonald who is
not a guy that gets off the bus you go
wow we gotta look out for him but he's a
walking double-double you know and he's
been great for that program because he's
from that part of the country and he's
he's the face of Northern Kentucky just
things like that I guess you get little
pieces from the coaches on and what they
expect and what their preparation is as
far as how to defend certain teams that
kind of thing so it's an interesting day
at the long day and actually this one's
more fun that the practices are bred for
people who don't understand that you
guys have four games today like how do
you first of all prepare yourself to
call four games and is there any
strategies is it water breaks is it
drinking a little bit of tea how do you
get through a day like today they used
to they used to tell us back when I was
CBS the first time they said if you have
a long enough break between games two
and three actually going and like change
your shirt and tie and pretend it's a
whole nother day I tried that first year
I did it didn't have any effect yeah
we've got we've got the honey in the tea
back in the green room and our people
are well prepared
five hour energy I hate to give up plug
for nothing but I'll give them a plug
because there'll be some of that
involved today too you know a lot of
preparation was done as soon as you find
out to your your bracket at Sunday night
when they let us know where you're going
you immediately start working and Monday
and Tuesday we're heavy preparation days
on my own before I got salsa on
Wednesday so you know you a lot of the
haze in the barn I think before you get
here then you try to pick up the little
nuances from the practices and all that
yesterday but you're so inundated you
know back in the day it was like you had
game notes or the people the SSID put
out a booklet you know coming into the
tournament and that was kind of what you
had we have so many emails from so many
different directions and so many
differents that lines and all of that
kind of stuff that I just went through
it right before you called I went
through my phone and I said okay here's
20 emails I'm getting rid of right now
because if I'm not ready I'm never gonna
be it it's not going to hold any good so
I got rid of most of my stuff just now
except with good gonna be CBSsports
n-c-double-a broadcast or Brad Nessler
joining the Rich Eisen show Kirk
Morrison here filling in for rich but
Brad how much of the of yesterday's
games did you get a chance to watch
because obviously some big story lines
coming out of those games and you got
not necessarily upsets but you had some
good victories teams that we're still
learning about how much did you get a
chance to actually follow the tournament
when you've got your own games ahead of
you well you know between your phones
and your iPads and Jimmy Jack's has had
his computer on out here while we were
watching practice and then back in the
green room we had another game going on
and then everybody's on their phone
every five minutes either checking their
brackets or checking the scores whatever
so you know we caught what we could I
you know I I think a star is made in
every region and you know John Moran I
heard you the highlights imminent he
went off and everybody kind of expected
that I don't know if they expected a
triple-double with 16 assists but it's
kind of jaw-dropping what some of the
kids do and fletcher mcgee i don't know
that much about walker because they're
not in my region but watching those guys
shoot threes yesterday was entertaining
and i think somebody else did 16 3
yesterday baylor maybe it gets Syracuse
something like that which is pretty
amazing that's the way to
kill a Syracusan so we watch as much as
we can while we're trying to prep
prepare for our own region and and
sometimes we say you know what I'm not
going to pay any attention to any other
region because I had too much on my
plate right here and then inevitably you
turn around and you're watching TV and
we went to a conference we have a big
conference room set up at hotel we
immediately went from all our practices
went back there turned on the TV at a
production meeting turned on the TV and
started watching ball so okay you catch
as much as you can when you have the
chance but it's pretty important to kind
of keep focused here but we do have a
lot of fun watching ball the other
regions the other broadcast these you
know Brad you've called some great games
whether it's college football college
basketball but when you have these great
games going on are great individual
performances for me my question to you
is how do you stay so calm in a moment
or how do announcers try to stay calm
in that moment when you look at you
mentioned Jay Moran I mean John Arendt
yesterday and even fletcher mcgee when
goes guys are having unbelievable
performances you can almost want to get
overly excited for what they're doing
yeah I and I do you know I'm calm when
it's just up and down the floor that's
the first half of a game but I'm I have
always loved shooters and so watching
that and watching French McGee I was
like man I wish I was doing that game
because when somebody starts raining
threes I don't know how many hits seven
or whatever and I know it went over 500
for his career but you know we've got
some of those kind of guys in this
region here just about every game we
have we've got the Player of the Year
their league so you expect you're gonna
have a star in just about every matchup
but when somebody all of a sudden goes
for 30 or gets really hot it starts
draining threes that's when I have a
blast so you kind of save it for the
moment you know if you've got a bunch of
guys that have 12 points it's not that
big a deal
but when you got a star out there and
you can tell the star is going to start
shining that's when you get excited and
I just get excited like any other fan
CBSsports Brad Nessler joining the
program Arizona State and the number 11
seed in your region in your region
taking on Buffalo we know Bobby Hurley
the former coach at Buffalo how was that
storyline kind of playing out so far I
know it's a look I won't call it tension
but obviously some familiar faces going
up against each other
yeah and you know you got natives Dave
Davis first job after being a high
school coach in Michigan for a long time
and so they're good friends you know and
that's just the way it is sometimes I
don't know if that bracket was set up
because there's no state had to play
their way in in the first floor so I
guess everybody looked at that said that
would be intriguing and we looked at it
obviously it's kind of going to be our
open to be honest with you when you
watch the game just because that's a fun
fact and I think you know Bobby had to
work really hard they went through the
pac-12 tournament got beat by Oregon and
then had to travel a date long trip
actually go home then go to date and
then come here they got here at 4:30
yesterday morning or something the
flight and Jim Jackson was on the
Charter with him to get here my
partner's do the game so it's been a
heck of a journey and you know Bobby got
a technical call the other night I did
the game where they played Arizona and
he was all fired up on that one too so
we were teasing him about keeping his
cool and he said I'm gonna be really
cool and I said yeah you told me that
against there is what have you told that
game so I always love I used to do is
James when he was at Duke so anytime
I've got a connection like that it's
it's interesting television and to match
up with his former team and Buffalo be
just like that you know Brett we've
already update our brackets did you fill
out a bracket for this one they kind of
keep it to the side and look at it at
the end or you just kind of leave that
to your colleagues you know I always
tell myself I'm not gonna fill one out
but I've got some high school buddies
that are on my case constantly and
they're like you gotta throw on that so
yeah I did and I did do very well if
they want I'll just burn I might as well
burn mine right now because it's not
going to matter it what it all comes to
an end did it Betty applet Brad Nessler
CBS Sports n-c-double a broadcaster
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
Kirk Morrison filling in for rich a
couple more minutes before I let you go
there you got a long day ahead Brad but
I kind of tell me about the environment
there in Oklahoma and Tulsa just because
you know a lot of times people don't
understand that this or these are you
know eight different fan bases all
coming together and sometimes you get
actually other schools pulling for
another school so how do you kind of
handle the the momentum swing of so many
different people coming together for
this tournament
it's different um you know last year I
was in Wichita Kansas was there at the
top seat and so the place was jammed and
even the practice sessions was crazy I
mean the arena was full I quite frankly
don't know what it's gonna be like Kurt
in the next hour before we tip over
whatever time we tip off here that
Northern Kentucky and Texas Tech are
warming up right now so it's getting a
little bit noisier in here I assume
Texas Tech's got a fairly good
contingent I think they might be one of
the closer drives maybe Iowa State to
but some of the other fan bases I don't
know if it's going to be just basketball
fans or if they travel well it's an
interesting it's an interesting thing to
see and you're right they have a
tendency the fans of one team or another
say well you know we don't want to play
those guys so we want them to get beat
so over the course of the day you're
gonna hear some teams cheering for other
teams when it's really not what colors
they're wearin understand that it's
different it's just start to fill up
yours I can't really tell you till game
one how to degree you know Brad that's a
different I don't know how many groups
of broadcasters they are for this for
CBS for this entire tournament but would
you say that your group with laven
Jackson and Washburn are you guys the
best-dressed group you think of of all
the CBS broadcast well the group you
know this year that's that level just
went up completely so Jo just walked
into anyway yeah as soon as he as soon
as he arrived on the scene automatically
we went up a notch as part look like
that well we appreciate your time today
Brad I know you guys got a lot of work
to get done well we will be watching man
good luck today and have a great rest of
the tournament
you got a Kirk Thank You Man as Brad
Nessler it's CBS broadcaster the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience